want to know what's heating up in  theaters this weekend Optimus Prime  do you seek retention not even Optimus  Prime can be trusted in the war for  Earth in transformer of last night  here is the bad that the future is  brutal and the cannibals are hungry in  the indie sci-fi romance the bad batch  ghosts loved here cost you an arm away  dad  no get a massage and all girls school is  turned upside down when a wounded Civil  War soldier arrives at their doorstep in  the beguile see with hot in theaters  with this week's anticipation so what's  your weekend take it going to be let us  know by commenting see you next time on  weekend ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]